hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play terror if now
it's been a while since I played an
oculus rift horror game and you all
remember what happened the last time
that I played it but I decided that it
was time to stop being a big bubble
blowing baby and get back into it
because there's better quite a few cool
games that have come out in the mirror
or the recent times and I want to play
in them for your entertainment I'm
always willing to throw myself into the
death and destruction for you guys
because I love you or something where's
my okay Oh oh good oh good for you okay
I'm gonna try not to shake my head very
much
I didn't even play test it this is
literally the first time in about three
months since oh good oh look what is
that what is that what is that oh it's
my torch okay that makes sense to have
it attached to my head so I'm supposed
to go that way
any minute now this looks a lot like
dread halts to be perfectly honest or
maybe it's because I haven't had this in
while seriously if you guys haven't had
a chance or if you guys ever have a
chance to play the oculus rift do it
okay eight open
okay what was that what is that what is
that oh you well I know what you are but
I mean why are you hi can I shove you in
my pants hello
somehow disturbing little girl there's
something here I'm supposed to have
there's something there
what are you what are you what are you
oh you're a lady are you a lady I can't
quite tell okay hi hello baby
how you doing don't seem to be doing
much
oh that's how it is so you're gonna have
a screaming contest rawr rawr
I'll go hey now you don't bother me I
won't bother you so something's I'm
supposed to do in here Can I grab that
axe it seems like it'd be pretty useful
I see you got your Beats Audio over
there you listen to some tunes and have
a nice day okay moving on
what's this the sideshow of Horrors I'm
supposed to go in each room in this all
go along
I wonder what awaits me in here hello it
still messes with my brain that I can do
that peek around corners well this ball
looks important what's going on here
is it something I'm supposed to do with
this bowl and that Miss Mel reduce
bottle I don't know about stabbers okay
is there another lady hiding in the
corner around here no what's the point
then there's something important
is there anything important somehow I
don't think so don't see anything that's
something supposed to pop up behind me
again I don't know about that
there's nothing here I don't even know
what I'm supposed to be doing in this
game like seriously you didn't give me
an objective or anything oh do I see
something down there is that a shadow
move it might be who knows let's run
towards it blindly
I really want to turn around okay all
right
Oh what is that oh yeah what is that
where's that I don't think I want to
know I hear that breathing again
can I go around it no maybe that's for
the best
I'm sorry did I step on your toe there
okay so there's one point of light over
there and total darkness over there I'm
gonna be an idiot and go over this way
that's what you guys would want me to do
because I love you and thank you
jigs I love my dicks that sounded weird
I love you guys and you guys aren't
dicks just shadow the door that looked
like an arm okay is that what is that
sort of cross what excuse me you want to
run that by me again
wait was there something there I didn't
even see anything was there actually
someone there oh hi lady
all right it's in my eyes did I break
anything okay where did I go
I got damnit I keep ruining my setup all
right got it oh hello
oh you're looking so fine today oh god
what is that is that your baby baby is
that your baby baby
hi oh hi hi how are you looking good oh
hello little girl
somehow you're the most disturbing of
them all okay so
there's a door there but there was the
hallway down here okay this is that all
about
what's this that wasn't all wait that
was there before okay nevermind that's
how I got to here I forgot it's easy or
it's amazing how quickly I forget things
okay making my way downtown walking fast
dropping pants and I'm home bound oh
good
a creepy red glow just what I've always
wanted
creepy blue glow creepy red glow
darkness point of light oh godö it's a
creepy red what's going on
oh yeah I want to walk down there quiet
quiet
I think good boo-ki nothing happened
really really tapestry I hear something
is that a real it's a real thing II I
think I'm supposed to collect those
pages but I didn't know I didn't have an
objective I'm gonna be an idiot now I'm
gonna go towards that noise
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I am so sorry okay never mind gotta go
this way Tao
ah good for me so I no choice I'm gonna
go back a bit because I feel like I may
have missed something because apparently
I'm supposed to collect these pages but
no one bothered to tell me why are they
even in this place couldn't that be home
sipping some tea
there was a door in here this is where I
found the first page I didn't see any
other pages before I don't think anyway
I may have missed something you guys
here a second set of
what's that what's that over there do I
want to know what that is
[Music]
Julie hey just find out what the hell
[Applause]
okay
that's a dick move how about you go
after yourself pin the a and have a
wonderful day
what's going on here some altar what did
happen minor Keys why oh no oh I done
goofed
I done goofed all right bring it on you
bastards you got me cornered but I'm
like a wild animal
I'll lash out rah rah rah rah dirty use
wherever you are near and far I will
rawr
till I know this is leading up to
something
probably a jump-scare hi heartbeat stops
my dead
[Applause]
[Music]
came out of a book
okay let's cool - damn it I ruined my
setup
what is that all okay hi lady yeah okay
cool all right what's the point of that
you popped it better that you'd be so
creepy why why did I've ruin anything on
my setup very complicated right now your
piece of ass damn it whatever moving on
I guess where am I going
what's the point of this the glowing
blue room with no purpose I want to come
home I'm gonna go home real bad why did
I come down this way I'm gonna go the
way I should have gone and go towards
that point a light over there yeah I'm
all crooked okay there we go
all right enough of this silliness back
to the heart God
what is that perfect
why are you just there oh my god I don't
to play I'm sweating I am literally
sweating oh man not from stress a rage
just from you know is that the shadow of
a person
yah blows the shadow of a Persian Oh
what are you what are you
[Music]
which is still behind right yes
okay take it away from it did I really
[Music]
okay yeah what is this over here oh it's
another shadow oh not again oh god what
is that oh cool a page my favorite okay
wait a minute
oh okay get out of here before pigs
thumpy thump watch step hump my rump no
thank you
all right I'm moving on ladies don't
bother me no thank you
I am okay
all right this is mildly comforting oh I
just had to say nothing no do I do
what do I do
[Music]
okay
what do I do
okay nothing's happening okay
where am I besides in darkness no what
is that oh it's another page
[Music]
[Applause]
okay okay hi
alright I'm out here scroll this screw
it all I don't wanna I don't wanna
there's only one place I haven't been I
think oh my god I want this nightmare to
be over let me double check I haven't
hit anything alright still going good
okay you're standing right there I know
lady but I gotta go around you you just
stay right over there yeah yeah okay oh
that's lovely
[Music]
what are you gonna do you gonna do okay
okay
so I think oh I hear a girl crying over
there wait there's kind of a seam in
this wall maybe I don't know
okay that thing is gone I think oh okay
okay enough enough enough enough okay
all right you had your fun I think I've
got all the pages what am I supposed to
do now
seriously I have no idea I really don't
know what am I supposed to do I've been
everywhere can I get out maybe I go back
the way I came
hi whoa
this has been a fun adventure but I'd
like to go home now if that's all right
with you guys okay
maybe that magic bowl Oh No
there is a place I don't know I don't
know what I'm supposed to do I don't
know
hello mister thumpy thump are you still
thumping around wait where the hell is
it I will go the other way
apologize for all my transgressions I
feel like there has to be another door
around here like on the opposite end or
something is the only room I haven't
been in entirely no causal eye as a
stone cold dirty lie it was right in
front of me I think okay I'm gonna go
maybe I gotta throw them down the well
like a wish I don't know I don't know oh
come on
is there nothing here there's nothing
here oh god I really don't know what
else to do guys I wish I did oh go where
do we go was it
oh where was it hi buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
all right I don't know what else to do
guys I've literally been everywhere
multiple times now are you like guarding
something is there something else here
that I need to know nice but unless
you're looking right at me okay I swear
I hear crying come from behind this wall
the only place I've been deterred from
is here so I think I gotta go this way
get around it somehow lure it out come
on come on
[Music]
[Applause]
come on come on come on come on
[Music]
okay this is either gonna totally screw
me or I'm gonna be good yeah yeah yeah
ah yeah I knew it there had to be
something all right lady crying lady
I heard you I'm here to rescue you your
knight in shining armor is here okay
Shakey's they didn't help my situation I
got one more page but I don't know what
to do with it still now the music's
gonna kick up again where'd you go no oh
come on
god dammit dammit I've been recording
for about 45 minutes now have you got
rid of marks on my face so uh I don't
know I couldn't find the end I really
couldn't I tried I really tried guys
than that I died I stupid I couldn't get
away from him but whatever it was
terrorists
hope you guys enjoyed it I don't think
I'll pick it up again so thank you all
so much for watching it was really good
no it was really good don't get me wrong
it was great horror game very scary I
loved it I loved it a lot but there was
no clear direction there was just not
enough information of what I was
supposed to do so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click antics and
I've done
[Music]
we never did
really salad
[Music]